[Music]
when i think of my blackness
it makes me feel powerful i just think
about everybody that's came before me
all of the struggles that black people
had to go through to get to where we are
gives me this feeling that i can
accomplish anything i'm the first
athlete to get a triple-double in their
college debut and doing that as a black
woman just makes it even better growing
up my mom would just tell us how being a
black woman is
almost like a double negative and that a
lot of people in society almost are just
nervous because of how how much power we
have and so i think there's always a
conversation about representation
matters and it's good to see women in
high roles but it's also really
important to see black women because not
just white women live in this world when
my basketball career is over i'd like to
be like an analyst and i look up to
somebody like carolyn peck i would love
to see more people doing that so i know
that there is there is hope for someone
that like me who wants to accomplish
something great